l'italien n'a plus de secret pour eux
l'opéra non plus dans le choeur des
enfants des écoles de saint quentin en
yvelines des trappistes dveri roi
désigne montant est désolant courtois je
sais vaguement à l'aide beaucoup de gens
là beaucoup de jeunes qui chante fort
mais j'aime bien les chansons des voix
et l'italien y avait là beaucoup plus
lent et ça fait j'aime bien qu'on salue
tous les beaux ils sont très durs en a
parlé c'est chaud chanter et en même
temps quand on quand on chante on
apprend on apprend quelques mots
quelques langues comme italien en
chantant surtout l'italien ils répètent
depuis le mois d'octobre pour emmener le
public en voyage un voyage historique et
musical au coeur de l'opéra une création
de pierre calme les c'est un scénario où
on va raconter on va parler des
personnages ont parlé d' orphée on va
parler de papageno on va parler de deux
personnages connus d'auteurs connus deux
pays ont fait de la géographie ont fait
l'histoire ont fait la mythologie
grecque ont fait du texte italien et 7,1
c'est un projet très globale pour eux et
des répétitions hebdomadaires d'une
heure au sein des écoles élémentaires
porté par l'association de promotion de
la musique classique
tout est nouveau pour eux mêmes la la
bonne respiration pour le chant est
nouveau il faut chanter des textes en
français ou en italien sur des mélodies
pas toujours très facile donc tout est
nouveau mais c'est à nous de leur faire
aimer cette star
plus que quelques jours de répétition
avant de rejoindre la scène du théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pour le moment les 300 élèves répètent
encore leurs gammes
kojima